[Music]
the smithsonian's national museum of
natural history has over 144 million
objects like this narwhal tusk
my name is kirk johnson i'm in charge of
all of them
99 of the collections are behind the
scenes and these are the people that
work with them this is carla dove from
the division of birds
here in the division of birds we have
somewhere around 620 000 museum
specimens
and that represents about 85 percent of
the diversity of birds in the world
you look at these specimens and you
realize that this is where the science
is really going to start we're using our
collections to identify birds that
collide with airplanes and help us
improve aviation safety
dr bob robbins curator of butterflies
and moths i have been professionally
employed as a lepidopterist we've worked
some butterflies for about 35 years this
is the essence of my being is to know
everything about butterflies there's a
whole
world out there that unless you look
very closely you don't see and it's an
interesting world it's a fascinating
world and it is full of practical value
for human beings
this is ellen strong curator of mollusks
what i love about this collection is its
breadth we estimate that we may have as
many as 20 million specimens
we are preserving a record of past life
on this planet of present life on this
planet and preserving that for the
future
i take that responsibility very
seriously in providing access and caring
for the specimens for posterity
dr jeff post curator of the national gem
and mineral collection
minerals in this collection go from
something that formed maybe in the last
few tens of years to others that formed
more than 3 billion years ago we know
right now there are more than 5 000
minerals that make up the earth and in
our collection we probably have more
than half of those each one's a little
piece of the puzzle and try to put all
these things together and hopefully
eventually understand the big picture of
how the earth works
and floyd shockley collection manager
for entomology
we have just a little over 35 million
specimens in the collection a third of
all insect life on earth is represented
by at least one specimen in our
collection when you look at a collection
the size of ours you're starting to get
to a point where you can ask really big
questions the questions related to
global climate change habitat
destruction and you can only answer
those big questions if you have a lot of
specimens collected over a long period
of time from a lot of different species
to understand the earth and the living
things of the earth you need to collect
those things and preserve them and study
them
and that helps you when you need food or
when you have a disease all that stuff
arcs back the fact that we have samples
of the whole planet here and that's how
we understand the planet
[Music]
if you have money that's been damaging a
fire in a flood that's been eaten by
insects or animals
we'll evaluate and determine how much is
there and reimburse you for it
[Music]
my name is eric walsh i'm the assistant
manager of the immunity currency
division
every year the melee currency division
receives about 23 000 cases people will
send money that's been somehow damaged
and re-reimbursed annually about 40
million dollars as a free service the
government provides that we pay a dollar
in dollar out
we require 51 of the note present to pay
on it and that just protects us from
paying twice on the same note
once we determine the amount we will
send a treasury check for what we
discover
we're pretty low tech here so the tools
of the trade are scissors knives
scalpels glue and tape and maybe a pair
of tweezers
the most challenging cases are usually
cases that the money has gotten wet and
set for long periods of times and it
will actually petrify and be solid as a
brick
a lot of is the dog ate my money we get
hundreds of those cases a year
a lot of people will hide their money in
the oven and forget about it or they'll
get it wet and put in the microwave and
that will ignite the currency
our most infamous case took place in the
80s and what happened was a farmer lost
his wallet in the field and discovered
that his cow had eaten it and we always
encouraged the submitter to send in the
package as it is and the farmer sent in
the cow's stomach which we were able to
retrieve the wallet from and reimburse
the farmer his currency
[Music]
our office consists of just under 20
people and we have 12 people that
examine and process the submissions
and they do roughly between 1 000 2 000
claims each year
we do get an increased amount of cases
after a national disaster over the past
year between the hurricanes and
wildfires out in california we've
reimbursed over two million dollars
we're called upon a lot of people hit
their low point so any relief that you
could provide someone after they lost
all their money in a flood or after
their house burned down it's very
rewarding
hopefully we're a service that you will
never need to use but in case something
does happen we're here for you
[Music]
i've been threatened by haiti with
voodoo over food
i've taken mangoes from passengers from
jamaica and been threatened with my life
never a dull moment here at jfk make it
easier
that's it
[Music]
the reason why we're confiscating all
this stuff is not because it's harmful
to the human being it's harmful for our
plants and our animals
this is a big port last month we
processed 1.5 million passengers you
figure between fruits and vegetables
you're talking about two or three
hundred kilos a day in just one terminal
so you're talking about four to six
hundred pounds
what kind of foods are you confiscating
every day is different every season is
different chinese new year christmas
easter
we have beef candy from china serrano
ham from spain we have lots of avocados
salami from italy no pedro i take it
back salami supremo that's spain also
once the food item is seized it's put in
what we call the contraband bin we drag
a contraim bin across the terminal it's
about a block long get a little exercise
and begin the process of grinding up all
the prohibited food items
we're at the grinder table
the officer will look and see if there's
any little exit holes or entry holes and
that's where you're going to find the
insect do you enjoy that part of the
process is it kind of a stress reliever
for you the grinder is great sometimes i
go home with a little bit of mango juice
and passion fruit juice on it just
having fun the water's splashing in your
face but this is what we have to do to
protect american agriculture as part of
our job
[Music]
money
it's everywhere
but what happens when your bills get old
and need to be replaced by new ones that
means old cash needs to be destroyed
a lot of cash
this is not however the story of money
growing on trees but of trees
growing out of money
well more like vegetables
we are here at the federal reserve bank
in new orleans and this is where we
shred millions of dollars
my name is dean mortha i'm the lead
business analyst for cash services here
at the new orleans fed we are the
nation's bank our job is to make sure
that we have a supply of currency also
part of that is to ensure that we remove
unfit old dirty currency from
circulation so here on average we shred
about six million dollars in dirty money
every day
this could be for any number of reasons
it could be because the note has rips in
it holes in it tears in it it could have
tape on it it could have graffiti
written all over it we don't want that
note going back into circulation if it
has any sort of those qualities will be
shredded
what we used to do is take all of these
currency shreds and they would just wind
up as waste going to a landfill
now through a lot of work and effort we
finally figured out a way where we can
take these shreds and ultimately recycle
them
so all that green leaves the fed and
heads to a compost facility where it
turns into something quite useful
what you're looking at right now is 24
million dollars but the soil that it
creates will be priceless
my name is jonathan christian
we turn cash into soil
it is definitely one of our secret
ingredients
it's little in content but it's huge in
what it provides
[Music]
currency that's deemed unfit it's
brought to our facility at wood
materials
from there we go through a simple
composting process where we convert that
into a healthy soil
our compost is used primarily by urban
farmers in the greater new orleans area
one of these farmers is simon minash and
this is a million dollar farm
we are making fresh local food
accessible
in new orleans
we've grown veggies herbs cucumbers
tomatoes and peppers
the vegetables we grow here are made out
of composted cash
it is very fulfilling to
be growing using a material that would
otherwise go to waste
one man's trash is another man's
treasure
and that's the story of how we grow
tomatoes
out of cash
[Music]